hello believe nation so we put out a ton
of top ten rules for success this year
it's been an amazing year tons of fun
tons of motivation and inspiration and I
thought what a cool idea might be to end
up this year is to share some of my
favorite top ten rules of success that
were all produced in 2016 to give you
guys one last clip to watch one last
jump of inspiration to go into 2017
strong I hope you enjoy my my systems
got a great thing now in this once in
every four months somebody sends an
email saying I've got a huge startup
that I want you to invest in but you've
got to sign this NDA right which
literally every time gets an email back
that says you write and and the reason
is I'm a humongous believer that ideas
are and that executions the game right
we've all got ideas everybody's got
ideas doing ideas we all have here we
can probably sit here for the next two
hours draw them all out record them and
predict the next 78 great startups over
the next nine years and so I think the
thing that is another theme in
entrepreneurship is there is way too
much fodder brought to the idea Hoover
was magic cab three years earlier uber
is not an idea
uber existed it's called magic cab but
the guys that executed sucked so they
lost so I think you know if there's any
level of romance left in this room about
your idea I'd like to suffocate it
because I think the actual situation is
what you actually do with it I talked to
so many smart fantastic ambitious
idealistic hard-working kids and they're
right out of college they're their
entry-level jobs and I'll ask them how
is it going and they'll say I think I'm
gonna quit and I'm like why they say to
me I'm not making an impact I'm like you
know you've been here eight months right
they treat the sense of fulfillment or
even love like it's a scavenger hunt
like it's something you look for my
millennial friends they've gone through
so many jobs they're either getting
fired I mean it was mutual or they're
quitting because they're not making an
impact or they're not find anything
they're looking for they're not feeling
fulfilled as if it's a scavenger hunt
love a job you find joy from is not
something you discover it's not like I
found love here it is I found a job I
love that's not how it works both of
those things require hard work you are
in love because you work very hard every
single day of your life to stay in love
you find a job that brings you ultimate
joy because you work hard every single
day to serve those around you and you
maintain that joy it's not a discovery
but the problem is the sense of
impatience it's as if an entire
generation is standing at the foot of a
mountain they know exactly what they
want they can see the summit what they
can't see is the mountain this large a
movable object that doesn't mean you
have to do your time that's not what I'm
talking about take a helicopter climb I
don't care but there's still a mountain
life career fulfillment relationships
our journeys the problem is this entire
generation has an institutionalized
sense of impatience and do they have the
patience to go on the journey to
maintain love to feel fulfilled or do
they just quit and on to the next dump
and on to the next ghost and on to the
next when I was about eight years old I
was I grew up in the church and I was
going to one of those women's day you
know how we we had we have Church all
day long I've been to Sunday school and
then we're going to and then afternoon
they were having a women's tea from the
women's board they were having a tea and
the little girl that was supposed to be
there to do recitation had gotten ill
and so they said to my stepmother we
need some
a little girl can Oprah come back and do
a recitation this afternoon my
stepmother said yeah I'll have her back
here this afternoon sir you know church
ain't over to 1:30
so by 4 o'clock I had gone home and
learned to recite Invictus by William
Ernest Henley now it starts out out of
the night that covers me black as a pit
from pole to pole I thank whatever God's
may be for my unconquerable soul I was
reciting it and doing the pit from pole
to pole I didn't know what I was saying
but at the end of the poem there is the
stanza that says it matters not how
Strait the gate how charged with
punishment the scroll I am the master of
my fate I am the captain of my soul now
my little eight-year-old brain didn't
really fully understand the power and
depth of those words but they sounded
good enough for me to write them down
and put them on my mirror and those
words I am the master of my fate I am
the captain of my soul became a mantra
for me what it said is I am responsible
for the choices that I make in my life
I am responsible I am responsible so
obviously I grew up and was better able
to articulate what those words really
mean and I discovered in physics class
those of you who remember physics the
third law of motion you remember what
that is the third law of motion in
physics says for every action it's
called Newton's law and it says for
every action there is an equal and
opposite reaction so what does that mean
that means everything that you are
putting out into the world every action
BAM there is an equal and opposite
reaction it means no matter what you do
the energy
what you do what you say and most
important the energy of who you are is
going out into the world into your home
into your relationships and that energy
is always coming back to you you are
responsible for the energy that you are
pulling out into the world because that
very energy BAM is coming right back to
you every single time whether you
believe it or not because it is law it
is law it is law that what you put out
into the world is coming back if you're
good at what you do people will
recognize that I really believe it I
really believe that going out and
playing good songs live as a great live
band will make you successful I'd really
think it will and it doesn't matter if
you're at that hold down the street or
you're on the side stage at Bonnaroo or
you're headlining well uh Palooza if
you're a great band with great songs
people will notice it that's it that's
all it is it's that simple product
placement and labels and ANR people and
all that bullsh it doesn't matter I
swear to god it doesn't matter and if
you back that up with the idea that just
playing those great songs in your great
live band is enough reward for you then
you're set but you've got to be badass
you just have to be really good it's the
other things that make up for your
musical inability you know I mean as a
drummer I never felt like I am gonna be
on the cover of Modern Drummer magazine
because I'm the best drummer in the
world I just do that if you put me on
stage without a PA or floor monitors in
a small club that I would beat the [ __ ]
out of my drums so much that people go
goddamn
did you see that drummer whoa and I'd
walk away from every show like there you
go
I just beat the piss out of those things
that people saw it people took notice
for sure and that was great
so at the end of the show I was a
successful musician because I had
achieved what I wanted to achieve so I
honestly believe I mean I know lots of
musicians that went down to South by
Southwest and said well it's easy for
you to say I'm like man I was in the
same position you are in twenty four
years ago that was it I worked in a
Furniture Warehouse and I wanted people
to like my music so I played out as much
as I could you know and if you really
honestly I'd like I said if you're
passionate and driven and focused in
what you do if you're really good at it
people will take notice that's basically
it I mean I don't understand the
industry I don't understand I don't
understand where music is headed I don't
really understand technology I just know
that when you walk into a club and you
see a band that blows you away
you are gonna follow that band you're
gonna either buy their CD or you're
gonna find them online or you're gonna
see them the next time they come to play
and it takes that's what it takes you
don't have to stand in line at the song
contest on TV to become a popular
musician you know to stand in front of
some judge that doesn't even play an
instrument on their own goddamn records
tell you now you're not gonna know right
that you know go blow people away in
front in their face and so it's gonna
you know it's it's I honestly believe
it's that simple
I got a uh yeah I started working at
this video store it was pretty much what
you're talking about around that time
and and it was great at first cuz I'd
always hated day jobs and stuff and so I
got a day job and it ended up being
pretty good but mentally I was there for
five years at a certain point it was our
narcotic all right I didn't have to keep
pursuing my dreams because you know it's
not what I want to do but it's sort of
kind of close
and if I didn't have an artist soul
burning in me I could have made myself
happy with that I could if i if i didn't
have an artist soul burning to get out i
could have you know walked backwards a
couple steps and just done that and i
would have been a fulfilling to anybody
else that would have been a fulfilling
life it wouldn't been for me because i
wouldn't know and i would have had
something to say that i didn't get a
chance to say but it did put me to sleep
for a while and and i've always just
thought i mean what really got it got
everything kind of truly going for me
you could point out a lot of different
things but the bottom line is the fact
that i realized that the even the group
of people i hung around with they were
all great great great fellows and great
gals but you know i was easy for me to
think that i was doing a lot because i
was doing more to try to move myself
forward than they were but you know
that's not yeah yeah okay i'm a big fish
in a puddle so what all right they're
not doing anything all right so yeah i'm
doing more than them but um i realized
that actually i need to get my ass out
to Hollywood and meet other people who
are you know like they were in my
category or or working a little higher
and and I should be the weakest link in
my chain that I have and that'll make me
be stronger or make me run faster I mean
like an analogy I've always used is
alright if you run the hundred yard dash
with a people that can't run as fast as
ya you'll win hands down you know that
but if you run with people much faster
than you alright
yeah you might come in last every single
time but your time will be better
because they're making you run all the
faster they're making making you dig
down just a little bit more it doesn't
matter that you and your time is faster
and that's what I knew I had to do I had
to get out of Loserville and throw
myself into a place where like this is
what I do for a living did you ever have
let's call it a normal job Connor a
nine-to-five yeah because the oldest
thing is the games were trade straight
away I was no different soon as I
finished skill I was orbs getting
pestered what are you doing with your
life you known this
and they didn't know what it was they
didn't know MMA wasn't no no no this
didn't know it could make a career as
far as they were concerned me mind I'm
talking about as far as they were
concerned of just getting into a cage or
fighting some other guy they didn't know
nothing about it
no one did really but I knew you know I
mean I knew or their and then I got it I
end up getting a trade just to keep them
quiet cause I had a lot of fights with
me dial-up my trade did you get I end up
getting a trade as a plumber and
literally opened the back eyes and our
open we closed the week-long mountain
and feeling like that birth site was one
of the biggest sites in Europe kill
Tiernan was right at that ski in place
huge and now it's just abandoned now
it's just deserted so I used to go up
there six o'clock folks folk rock
Romano's on that and 50 I just have to
walk to the end for about half an hour
from your helps wait for some memory
card I didn't even know he drove in the
air for and I have to flag him down
nightmare yeah two hours down on the m50
two hours by usually 14-hour days and I
was there I was the first year so I was
the I had to go and do everything like
to go to the shop I had to go and get
this and get that so I always had
trouble down I was like this isn't for
me this is not for me
and I'm did you last I lasted 18 18
months stealing well it was tough you
know just it wasn't wasn't the life for
me and I mean then and then John said
because I was training with jhana as
well at the time and then John got on
Twitch and says there I have a show on
the show would like to fight honey and
then that was he I just packed it in
didn't show up weed I used to come in
and punch the head on me and like try
and drag me out of bed and I just
wouldn't go and only had opal or for a
good few years when I'm all verbal and
and that was there I just packed it in
quit and then focused on training and
that's I knew I knew I knew what was
gonna happen I knew I was gonna get here
they didn't there's a lot of stressful
years you know a lot of tough times and
but I proved them wrong I proved myself
right the only thing that stops you from
getting what you want in life is the
bullet store and you tell yourself of
why you can't have it you get that what
stops you back is the story because the
story
stops you from getting honest and if you
can't get honest with yourself there's
no way you can go what made you like
this success in sales in life it's like
a road map right you know where you want
to go and you have this
perfect strategy the straight line to
get there it's a perfect strategy it's
gonna get you there every single time
but if you don't know your starting
point if you're not getting eyes where
you actually are it doesn't matter how
powerful the strategy is and it doesn't
matter how powerful your goal is I'm
gonna actually set a goal today write a
60 day goal and let's say you really set
this goal and I'll show you how to do it
in a brilliant way so it's visceral so
it makes you really feel it you see if
you sense if you smell a goal that's
step one I'm gonna teach you the
straight line which is your strategy to
get to your goal but if you're not
honest with where you all right now your
starting point the map is worthless
there's three things that you need to
know where you are where you want to go
and how you're gonna get there those are
the three things you must have to take
advantage of any opportunity I'm gonna
give you the strategy I'm gonna a [ __ ]
tell me exactly where you want to go for
yourself you got to get honest don't
blame the boss don't blame the leagues
don't blame your job go in the industry
or in just get honest you don't like
your industry find another one you don't
have to compromise yourself you know
it's something you don't feel good about
then don't do it the most important
choices I made was to say no I said you
know many a times in two films that I
just did especially early on that just
didn't feel calm
it was one scoop that was brought to me
I call that the negative you couldn't
kill
like use excuse raping this wife in the
40s to do when they try to hang on buddy
so I actually call I was fortunate at a
time but it still to be able to call and
I said you know this movie make it I'm
sick and they offered me six hundred
thousand dollars to play they couldn't
and
he said to me and I'll say this to you
he said the first two or three or four
films to make a decision to dental will
determine how you ever see
he said I'm not going to tell you what
to do but remember that the first three
or four or five from Jamaica in the
tournament on your PC I turned it down
I turned money back I needed to turn it
down six months later I got try to free
if you don't feel like I should do it
then don't do it because you don't want
to be you know you don't wanna be a
negative energy on the set that's how I
feel something you know or I ain't doing
this is I'm gonna slap somebody the
second day
I think decisions you can make as an
actor actress is saying no they saying
no you don't have to take your clothes
off if you don't I love me so the day
that you decide to stop loving me I'm
not gonna love myself any less I believe
in me if you stop believing in me I'm
not gonna believe in myself any less if
you believe that I'm irrelevant that no
one is checking for me and that I don't
mean anything to the world because you
think or believe that about me
it doesn't believe it doesn't mean that
I'm gonna believe it about myself see
the day that you start living your life
according to everybody else's opinion is
the beginning of the end most of y'all
and it's tough I see it every day all
day most of you guys don't actually know
your self-worth you don't know your self
value so you're like a vulnerable little
child and you're you're shaking and it's
like everybody loves me this week so I
love me this week next week it drops so
now you're running around insecure
feeling self-conscious and not loving
yourself sad and depressed
based on the feedback the response is
and the energy that the rest of the
world is giving you I wrote about this
in my new book which is coming it's
called black rose it hasn't been
released yet but it's coming I talked
about the fact that fame is an addiction
fame is one of the most unspoken
addictions out there so many celebrities
and entertainers athletes and public
figures they base their self-worth on
their relevancy based on everybody in
the world checking form and as soon as
people stopped checking form then they
stopped checking for they self y'all
don't love me no more
I'm not selling records I'm not number
one in the box office no more I'm not
making as much money as I used to make
Oh ain't nobody checking for me so guess
what I'm not checking for myself no one
sees the value in me anymore so I don't
see the value of me anymore every time I
go on Twitter Facebook they say I'm
irrelevant
so I'm irrelevant to myself now I ain't
because you think that I ain't no one
loves me because you said no one loves
me I don't love me the day that you
allow the opinions of the outside world
to dictate the way you feel about
yourself it is the beginning of the end
of you living a blessed and self loving
secure life I can tell y'all right now
that it is not the car that I Drive or
any de jure that I own or the size of my
house that defines my self-worth I'm hot
I'm hot I'm hot when you don't think I'm
hot I'm amazing when you don't think I'm
amazing I love me even if you stop
loving me you can say that nastiest
meanest evilish that you could have a
conjure up it will never change the way
I feel about myself I'm telling you
that's the way I live my life that's how
I feel about me most of y'all are on
Twitter you're desperate for likes
you're desperate for the the the the
egotistical feeding frenzy feed my ego
Fifi feed like me like me because I
don't like me I'm telling y'all right
now the day that you allow the opinions
of everybody on the outside world to
define your day to day month a month and
year to year it's the beginning of the
end
love yourself believe in yourself love
yourself believe in you
so independent of the validation of the
world have opinions and feelings about
yourself independent of the feedback why
you got to have somebody calling you
beautiful everyday in order for you to
feel beautiful do you believe that
you're beautiful or do you only believe
you're beautiful when other people say
that you're beautiful
I'm just asking self-love is the cure to
self hate if you make it to the end of
this video I want you to write self love
is the cure to self hate these are the
type of qualities that I'm going and
have been in stealing in my daughter
there is no man that you could ever meet
Shayla that can make you feel more
amazing than what you're supposed to
feel about yourself nobody wants to be
alone but if you show up empty as an
empty shell and you're expecting this
man to fulfill you and fill you up with
all a little of that doesn't exist you
gonna be freed up because as soon as he
leaves you depleted you're empty and you
have nothing left for yourself again
never rely or depend on anybody to
fulfill your heart and if you don't
believe in the Lord Jesus Christ you
better get to know him because that's
also a part of the process of self-love
you are supposed to love yourself
independent of any feedback comments
likes shares in any of all of these
other social medias some of y'all are
social media [ __ ] what does that mean
I ain't until people on my timeline tell
me that I'm the I love me independent of
anything that anybody could ever say has
nothing to do with being arrogant
egotistical it's just a matter of
knowing and being aware of self-worth I
love you if you make it to the end of
this video I want you to write self-love
is the cure to self hate self-love is to
cure to self hate and I hope you share
this video because I want this video to
spread all over the world send it to
WorldStarHipHop send it to all of the
blogs and the websites self-love is the
self-hate Shabana tyrese spreading love
always share share share click that
share button spread love love circle I
love you always it's hard changing your
life it was hard when just over three
years ago in the Penobscot building in
Detroit Michigan where I was operating
my business and I fell on some hard
times and I was sleeping in my office
it was hard coming into the lobby and
the security said scuse me mr. Brown can
we see you for a moment
and I said yes and I walked up to the
counter and he gave me an envelope and
he said would you mind reading it here
and I opened the envelope and the
envelope was from management that says
this is an office tower it's not a hotel
please
do not sleep in your office and I said
excuse me sir I said I just worked long
hours in creating my business I'm an
entrepreneur and right now things are
bad for me but they're not going to be
this way always and I just asked for the
opportunity to continue to operate like
I'm doing I'm not trying to make this my
home and it was hard coming through the
lobby and sometimes they would laugh
there's a guy talking about becoming
successful and look at him he's bathing
in the bathroom upstairs on the 21st
floor he sleeps on the floor him and two
other dreamers up there look at him
it was hard ladies and gentlemen coming
to speak to people and I was facing
financial difficulties in my own life I
was behind on my bills and my dreams and
I'm saying to them you can live your
dream it was hard ladies and gentlemen
it was very difficult to pick myself up
each day believing that I can do it
there were times that I doubted myself
and say God why why is this happening to
me I'm just trying to take care of my
children and my mother I'm not trying to
steal a Rob from anybody how did this
have to happen to me it was very hard
and here's what I want to say to you for
those of you that have experienced some
hardships don't give up on your dream no
one could have convinced me by holding
on by continuing to push forward by
continuing to run toward my dream that
one day I would have my own talk show
it's a long shot ladies and gentlemen
from Liberty City an abandoned building
order floor never annoying my mother or
father it's a long shot
being here with you today in this Dome
in Atlanta it's a long shot
no college training labeled educable
mentally [ __ ] but I kept running
toward my dream
goes down
goats down
[Applause]
[Music]
don't stop running to watch your dream
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I'm really curious to
find out which one that you guys like
the best
who was your favorite speaker what was
your favorite rule please leave in the
comments below I'm gonna join in the
discussion finally when they give a
quick shout-out to Bertha Nene thank you
so much for picking up a cup of my book
your one word it really really really
means a lot to me and I hope that you
find your one word so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one where it is
much love I'll see you soon